- We'll get started.
Good morning.
My name is Lou Tiseo,
I'm the Senior Director
for Foundational Technologies and ITS.
I am also co-sponsor with
our chief information
security officer on what we called
the Next Generation Network
which is this session's about.
I was going through the
website this morning
and I was looking at
this and I was like, wow.
‘Strengthening Our Network,’
what does that mean?
And for me it means the foundation,
strengthening the foundation
of our network across campus
is important to me.
So it was great to see this
theme for this conference.
So the Next Generation Network,
ultimately what is does
is it provides more a
modern, resilient, secure
network across campus but it has a much,
a bigger reach even outside of campus.
The network itself is very old,
and we're seeing today
more and more demands
on that network to help
advance the research,
especially research, the clinical care,
and the academic areas.
I was at a conference a few weeks ago
called the Common Solutions Group.
It was about 20 universities
that attended nationwide.
Out of all the places, it was in Nebraska
so went to the University of
Nebraska for this conference.
And one of the topics there was talking
about campus networks.
There was about 10
universities that were doing
very similar to what we're
doing, what you're gonna see
about how we're gonna
modernize our network.
Different stages, different areas,
but the question was really
what's driving the change?
Security is huge for us, and
I don't mean cybersecurity
from external attacks.
That's there, we have defenses for that,
but it's internally as well.
It's when people bring their own devices,
they get on the network, there's
things that are happening.
There's a lot of what we
call east-west traffic
within the network that
we don't know sometimes
what's happening or even
hard to find where it is.
Increased devices, IOT devices,
brings your own devices,
AV on the network, it
just keeps getting bigger
and more and more demand on the network
from packets to demand to bandwidth.
The average student today brings
between six to eight devices to school
that want to attach to the network.
Gaming systems, iPads, phones, iWatches,
IOT devices, doorbells for their rooms.
I mean so it just continues
to grow and then grow.
Applications moving to the Cloud,
I can personally speak about this
because I ran the Cloud technologies group
and the push for size applications,
Infrastructure as a Service, AWS, Azure,
Google Platforms, doing
compute out in the Cloud,
big data storage out in the Cloud.
This is taxing our network
going out of the university
and how do we handle that?
Higher speeds for research,
moving data across the university.
We have a high performance
computing center west campus,
they need to move big
amounts of data over there
for the 40,000 cores that they
have to process that data.
And now we're even
talking about regionally.
How do we collaborate with UMass
and all these other
institutions on the Northeast?
I'm a member of a Northeast
regional network team
that's trying to build
a much faster network
throughout the northeast.
There's one on the west
coast it's called Quilt,
it's very similar.
But these are big demands,
especially in research.
Bring your own devices,
I talked about that,
just attaching a Wi-Fi.
We can have an average of about
30,000 people on the network
in a peak day which is quite
big, just for this campus.
What I talk about too
is the technical debt
and a lot of universities are seeing this,
you know the investment in the network
was never really there
over the last 10 years,
however the network technology
has taken leaps and bounds
in the last 10 years of the technology
from software defined networking
to software defined access,
to perimeters that we
put in and being able
to machine learn devices
that come on the network
and how do we deal with it?
I talked a little bit about
the growing dependencies.
So for Yale, academic delivery, right?
Books online.
I have a son that's going
to college next year
and they're actually now
selling pages online,
pages of a book that you
can buy for a week, right?
On a specific topic.
So you know the demand more
for video and stuff like that
in the academic delivery is
getting bigger and bigger.
Research, I talked about that.
It's just very overwhelming
for me even just
to figure out how this data gets moved.
We're actually talking about
how do we actually move
the compute to the data using
what we call containerization.
You know, we built containers here,
and I'm gonna move those
containers to UMass
and let them process on their data.
So the collaboration with
the other universities is big
and just even on campus.
We have what we call the science network
and the science network
is a physical network,
it's a 100 gig network but it's only
in specific buildings that are needed.
Like, there's no science
network in this building
but there is one getting ready
for the big science
building that's coming up.
Clinical care as many of
you know, I mean you know
the call centers today we run call centers
on the Yale School of Medicine side.
You call them, everything's
on the computer.
They know who you are,
they know what apartments'
you're gonna have,
what your test results look like,
things like that to help you through
and even to the point where these doctors
are in the Yale Health Plan
where they have carts and stuff
that need to connect to the
network, things like that.
So no more paper anymore.
We were just talking the other
day about Milford Hospital
we all know New Haven Health Services
borrowed Milford Hospital.
Well they were never computerized
to the point where we are today.
I mean, they have basic computerization,
but a lot of their records
were, are manual records
which is, they're gonna be
spending quite a bit of money
on getting Milford
Hospital up and running.
And of course the cultural heritage side
for worldwide scholars.
The biggest challenge for us in this area
is that digital born
collections are very important
and how do you preserve those?
Where do you preserve those?
You know, you have to save those
in like eight different places
around the country sometimes.
So I'm working actually very closely
with the library on trying to define
do we need a cultural heritage
digital collection type
of network built into our architecture
and what does that mean for the museums
as well as the libraries
that are tied to it?
Very simple.
We have a very aging network, very old,
mixture of many, many
different technologies.
It's a complete comprehensive replacement
of the hardware throughout the network
and I'll show you the
numbers what that means.
The security side of this is
gonna built into the network.
It's a different type of model
on how we actually
intercept different things
that are happening on the network,
how we can pick up a
device that's across campus
and say oh, that's playing really badly.
I just wanna put it over here.
Put him in a different
network that's kinda safe.
Where today, a lot of times
you'll see part of my team
running out of the building trying
to go find that in the building, right?
So it's very, very manual process.
And we'll talk about
the number of networks.
So the key thing really
for me is the reliability,
the resiliency, the
visibility of this network.
Pictures tell a thousand words here,
and this is not the worst
one, I'll just tell you.
This, you know that
pipe I hit my head on it
when I went to go see it.
So you know we have the
physical state of the network,
just even the closets
that are around campus
are in really poor shape.
They're not managed properly.
There's a lot of work
that needs to be done
just in the conditioning of some
of these old buildings that we have to do.
And the project itself,
you know I'll give you
a little preface on how
this project happened.
You know, it's a five year project
and I spent probably eight months working
with the budget advisory groups,
the financial committees,
the business office,
all the way up to the board of directors
on presentations for this and
we've been fully approved.
Not committed, but fully approved
to spend $50 million to
replace this network.
So it's a big number.
As you can tell here, 55% of the equipment
is beyond its recommended service age.
The segmentations are a concern
to the security side of things.
Just standards in general,
I mean we probably have
about four different
types of manufacturers
of switching equipment and Wi-Fi points.
So here are the key deliverables.
So we need to remediate about 1,400 rooms,
closets that connect all
the floors in one building.
So this could range from a
complete redo to the room
to just wiring, to just
even securing the room.
We have rooms where
they're just in closets.
We have a room that's in,
to get to it you have to go
through the women's restroom.
You know, so it's very
difficult to even keep control
of these rooms just from
a physical standpoint.
Some of the them don't
have key, locks on it,
or proxy locks on it.
We find people put things
in it like a microwave
in a room or something like that,
so we have to take better
control of these rooms.
And you know everything
from even air conditioning,
and power, and fiber
connections to specific rooms.
So it is a very lengthy process here
a long assessment that
has to go on with this
but it's gonna go on
for the next five years,
just assessing and remediating the rooms.
We're replacing about 9,000 devices,
that includes Wi-Fi devices as well.
The Wi-Fi devices, we have
actually a big investment
in newer Wi-Fi devices
so we'll let them age out
and replace them as they
get replaced over time.
Consolidating five networks,
and we're focused on five networks only
because those are the
five biggest networks.
We have many other physical networks,
and these are physical so
if you go into a closet,
you will see a rack of switches
three times, let's say,
one for a facilities network,
one for a public safety network,
one for a campus network.
That's gonna come together
through software defined
networking right, into one architecture.
Role-based access, you'll
see in the back part
as we go through the presentation
that role-based access
is defining who you are
and what you get on the network.
There's researchers who are
gonna need 100 gig connections
and we can define that for a researcher,
where you can have the
administrative offices
just needs access and
maybe needs like you know
a five gig connection versus
a hundred gig connection.
Who you are, where you are is gonna define
your different roles.
If I'm a clinician, I wanna
be able to move from here
to Yale New Haven Health
and be able to use
my same ID and not have multiple IDs.
That's the role-based access piece of it.
And automating cybersecurity responses,
I spoke a little bit
about it but it's more
machine-based responsing
versus manual responsing.
So I talked a little bit
about these in the last slide
but a seamless user experience
no matter what profile you're in,
if you're just a student
where you deal with LORIS data
or if you're a clinician
who deals with HIPAA
or a researcher that deals
with different other,
like FERPA or ePHI data.
You know it's gonna be seamless.
You go here, you go to
a different network,
you know over to the Med Campus
which is a different network,
and you'll have that seamless connection
to all your resources,
even if you're VPN in,
it'll be the same thing.
You'll just be looking like a
remote site onto the network.
Faster speeds are gonna
go 10 to 40 times faster.
I mean, really the network
it's not the fiber,
it's not the cabling in the network,
it's the switching, right?
So we change these switches
to a much more robust
and faster switching technology.
Fewer network disruptions.
I've been in this position now
for a little bit over a year.
I made it very visible on weekly updates
about outages that are
happening around campus.
It's all the way to the provost.
You know, this week we had eight outages,
three buildings down, and
it was important to do that
because we never did that before
and giving that visibility really shows
the concern that we've had.
Machine speed detection
for breaches again,
built into the network there's
this security defined access
and they call ICE which
is another piece of it
and DNA Center which
that is going to help
with machine detection
and visibility of where
things are happening.
Like I said, it's very,
very difficult today
to actually find things.
Here's a very high level schedule.
We spent a good part of FY19 really,
from a programmatic
perspective, building a team.
We are moving to all Cisco technology.
I had got a lot of questions about that.
We actually have Cisco here on
site for the next two years,
their advanced services
in engineering's teams
are here working with the teams.
We have a number of different
providers that work with Cisco
that are here to help us with
deployment and architecture.
So we spent this year
really programmatically
bringing the team together,
understanding what it means,
and working on the design
and architecture piece
of this program.
We're starting with some pilot buildings,
probably I think soon,
very soon, this summer.
25 Science Park is gonna be the first one,
'cause we're gonna eat our own
dog food and learn from that.
But we're taking two
administrative buildings
on Central Campus here
and then there's been
a little bit of a turn of the tides
because of some recent
things that have happened
with the Med School Campus network,
but we are accelerating
deployment on the Med School side
to correct some major issues there.
So over the next, once we
get through the pilot cycle,
I think once we get through FY20,
we'll have a whole
deployment plan ready to go
for the next few years
and it's just really going
through each of these buildings.
Up front of this there's a couple
of other work streams like I mentioned.
We're looking at the whole
fiber plant on the university,
making sure we have diverse connections,
and, did I shut this off?
We're going out.
I'll speak louder.
It looks like it went out.
So we're looking at the rooms and stuff,
so we're trying to get
that what we call layer one
set in place before we start
putting in the electronics.
Okay?
So, we're defining this
in two different releases.
The foundational release,
which I mentioned before
is focused on resiliency, reliability,
stability, visibility, and
hopefully when we do that phase,
my emails each week to the provost
and the down buildings will
reduce down to nothing,
'cause that's really the
primary focus of this.
And then moving into the
advanced security side of things,
we have a lab setup now at Science Park
and you know we're gonna
have teams of people,
public safety coming in
trying all their devices.
Facilities has an enormous amount
of devices just to run a building.
They need to test all those in the lab
before we roll out and config those.
When you plug something into the network,
if it is not defined
through a configuration,
it will not allowed on the network.
It will be put in a space that has
to have a config made for it, type, right?
So we're hoping that
over time that that will
that will be easily done
to allow those devices,
but we do get devices
plugged into the network
that spew a lot of different traffic
that hurts our network today.
So where are we?
I spoke a little bit about this.
Designs are 80% complete.
Our teams are still
building but the core team
is been working the last year
on the implementation side
of things as well as
for the pilot buildings,
and then looking ahead for what
the next couple years look like.
What's next is again the
detail migrations plans.
We're gonna focus out on
West Campus in the beginning
probably as the normal project begins,
only because we have a
little more flexibility
with the layer one piece of West Campus,
so from a physical plant standpoint.
Use cases, we need to build use cases.
That's one of our next steps as well.
Meeting with the research community,
meeting with the clinical community,
meeting with the facilities community,
and understand all the use
cases that need to happen
for those areas and
also the academic side.
That's all I have.
Well, I'll be around for a little while
if there's any other questions
and thank you very much.
Enjoy the rest of your day.
(audience clapping)